The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's start.
So we are back to calculating
partition functions
for Ising models.
So again some in general
hypercubic lattice
where you have
variables sigma i being
minus plus 1 at each side with
a tendency to be parallel.
And our task is to calculate
the partition function which
for n sides amounts
to summing over 2
to the n binary configurations
of a weight that
favors near neighbors to be in
the same state with a strength
K.
OK.
So the procedure that
we are going to follow
is this high
temperature expansion,
that is writing this as
hyperbolic cosine of k 1
plus t standing for
tan K sigma i, sigma j.
And then as we discussed,
actually this i
would have to write as a
product over all bonds.
And then essentially to
each bond on this lattice
I would have to either assign
1 or t sigma i, sigma j.
Binary choice now
moves to bonds.
And then we saw that
in order to make sure
that following the
summation over sigma
these factors survived we have
to make sure that we construct
graphs where out of each side
go out an even number of bonds.
And we rewrote the
whole thing as 2
to the n, cos K to the
number of bonds, which
for a hypercubic lattice is dn.
And then we had
a sum over graphs
where we had an even
number of bonds per side.
And the contribution
of the graph
was basically t to the power
of the number of bonds.
So I'm going to call
this sum over here s.
After all, the interesting
part of the problem
is captured in this factor
s, these 2 to the n cos K
to the power of dn
are perfectly well
behaved analytical functions.
We are looking for
something that is singular.
So this s I can either pick
one from all of the factors--
so to the lowest order in t
I would have to do to one.
And then we saw that the
next order correction
would be something
like a square,
would be this t to the 4th.
And then objects that are
more complicated versions.
And I can write all of those
as a sum over kind of graphs
that I can draw on the lattice
by going around and making
a loop.
But then I will have graphs that
will be composed of two loops,
for example, that
are disconnected.
Since this can be translated
all over the place
this would have a factor
of n for a lattice that
is large for getting side
effects and edge effects.
This would have a contribution
once I slide these two
with respect to each other.
That is, of the
order of n squared.
And then I would
have things that
would three loops and so forth.
Now based on what we
have seen before it
is very tempting to somehow
exponentiate this sum
and write it as
exponential of the sum
over objects that
have a single loop.
And I will call this new sum
actually s prime for reasons
to become apparent
because if I start
to expand this
exponential, what do I get?
I will certainly
start to get 1, then
I will have the sum
over single loop graphs
plus one half whatever is in
the exponent over here squared,
1 over 3 factorial whatever
is in the exponent, which is
this sum cubed, and so forth.
And if I were to
expand this thing that
is something squared,
I will uncertainty
get terms in it that
would correspond
to two of the terms in the sum.
Here I would get things that
would correspond to three
of the terms in the sum.
And the communitorial
factors would certainly
work out to get rid
of the 2 and the 6,
depending on-- let's say
I have loop a, b, or c,
I could pick a
from the first sum
here, b from the
second, c from the third
or any permutation thereafter
that would amount to c.
I would have a factor of c abc.
But s definitely is not equal to
s prime because immediately we
see that once I square this term
a plus b squared, in addition
to a squared ab I will also
get a squared and b squared,
which corresponds to
objects such as this.
One half of the same
graph repeated twice.
Right?
It is the a squared term that
is appearing in this sum.
And this clearly has no
analog here in my sum s.
I emphasize that in
the sum s each bond can
occur either zero or one time.
Whereas if I exponentiate
this you can see that s prime
certainly contains things that
potentially are repeated twice.
As I go further I could
have multiple times.
Also when I square this
term I could potentially
get 1 factor from 1, another
factor, which is also
a loop from the second term, the
second in this product of two
brackets, which once
I multiply them happen
to overlap and share something.
OK?
All right.
So very roughly
and hand wavingly,
the thing is that s has
loops that avoid each other,
don't intersect.
Whereas s prime has
loops that intersect.
So very naively s is
sum over, if you like,
a gas of non intersecting loops.
Whereas s prime is a
sum over gas of what
I could call phantom loops.
They're kind of like ghosts.
They can go through each other.
OK?
All right.
So that's one of a
number of problems.
Now in this lecture
we are going to ignore
this difference between s and
s prime and calculate s prime,
which therefore we will
not be doing the right job.
And this is one example of where
I'm not doing the right job.
And as I go through
the calculation
you may want to figure out
also other places where
I don't know correctly
reproduce the sum s in order
to ultimately be able
to make a calculation
and see what it comes to.
Now next lecture we will try
to correct all of those errors,
so you better keep track
of all of those errors,
make sure that I am
doing everything right.
Seems good-- all right.
So let's go and take a
look at this s prime.
So s prime, actually, log of
s prime is a sum over graphs
that I can draw on the lattice.
And since I could
exponentiate that,
there was no problem in the
exponentiation involved over
here.
Essentially I have to,
for calculating the log,
just calculate these
singly connected loops.
And you can see that
that will work out fine
as far as extensivity
is concerned
because I could translate
each one of these figures
of the loops over the lattice
and get the factors of n.
So this is clearly
something that is OK.
Now since I'm already making
this mistake of forgetting
about the intersections
between loops
I'm going to make
another assumption that
is in this sum of single loops.
I already include things
where the single loop
is allowed to intersect itself.
For example, I'm going to
allow as a single loop entity
something that is like this
where this particular bond will
give a factor of t squared.
Clearly I should not include
this in the correct sum.
But since I'm
ignoring intersections
among the different groups
and I'm making it phantom,
let's make it also phantom
with respect to itself,
allow it to intersect
itself [INAUDIBLE].
It's in the same
spirit of the mistake
that we are going to do.
So now what do we have?
We can write that
log of s prime is
this sum over loops of
length l and then multiply it
by t to the l.
So basically I say that I can
draw loops, let's say of size
four, loops of size six.
Each one of them I have
to multiply by t to the l.
Of course, I have to multiply
with the number of loops
of length l.
OK?
And this I'm going to
write slightly differently.
So I'm going to say
that log of s prime
is sum over this
length of the loop.
All the loops of
length l are going
to contribute a
factor of t to the l.
And I'm going to count
the loops of length
l that start and
end at the origin.
And I'll give that
a symbol wl00.
Actually, very soon
I will introduce
a generalization of this.
So let me write the definition.
I define a matrix
that is indexed
by two side of the
lattice and counts
the number of walks that I can
have from one to the other,
from i to j in l steps.
So this is number of walks
of length l from i to j.
OK?
So what am I doing here?
Since I am looking at
single loop objects,
I want to sum over,
let's say, all terms
that contribute, in
this case t to the 4.
It's obvious because it's
really just one shape.
It's a square, but this square
I could have started at anywhere
on the lattice.
And this slight factor, which
captures the extensivity,
I'll take outside because
I expect this log of s
to be extensive.
It should be proportional to n.
So one part of it
is essentially where
I start to draw this loop.
So I say that I always
start with the loops
that I have at point zero.
Then I want to come
back to myself.
So I indicate that the end
point should also be zero.
And if I want to
get a term here,
this is a term that
is t to the fourth.
I need to know how many
of such blocks I have.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are you allowing
the loop to intersect itself
in this case or not?
PROFESSOR: In this case, yes.
I will also, when I'm
calculating anything
to do with s prime I
allow intersection.
So if you are asking whether I'm
allowing something like this,
the answer is yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And are we assuming
an infinitely large system so
that--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That's right.
So that the edge effects, you
don't have to worry about.
Or alternatively you can imagine
that you have periodic boundary
conditions.
And with periodic
boundary conditions
we can still slide it
all over the place.
OK?
But clearly then the
maximal size of these loops,
et cetera, will be
determined potentially
by the size of the lattice.
Now this is not entirely
correct because there
is an over counting.
This 1one square that
I have drawn over here,
I could have started
from this point,
to this point, this point.
And essentially for
something that has length l,
I would have had l
possible starting points.
So in order to avoid the over
counting I have to divide by l.
And in fact I could have started
walking along this direction,
or alternatively
I could have gone
in the clockwise direction.
So there's two
orientations to the walk
that will take me
from the origin back
to the origin in l steps.
And not to do the over counting,
I have to divide by 2l.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If we allow
walking over ourselves
is it always a degeneracy of 2l?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
You can go and do the
calculation to convince
yourself that even for
something as convoluted as that,
you can... is too.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So this is what we
want to calculate.
Well, it turns out that
this entity actually
shows up somewhere else also.
So let me tell you why I wanted
to write a more general thing.
Another quantity that
I can try to calculate
is the spin spin correlation.
I can pick spin zero
here and say spin r here,
some other location.
And I want to calculate
what is the correlation
between these two spins.
OK?
So how do I have to do
that for the Ising model?
I have to essentially sum
over all configurations
with an additional factor
of sigma zero sigma
r of this weight, e to the k,
sum over ij, sigma i, sigma j,
appropriately normalized,
of course, by the partition
function.
And I can make the
same transformation
that I have on the first line
of these exponential factors
to write this as a
sum over sigma i,
I have sigma zero, sigma
r, and then product
over all bonds of these factors
of one plus t sigma i, sigma j.
The factors of 2 to the
n cos K will cancel out
between the numerator
and the denominator.
And basically I will
get the same thing.
Now of course the denominator
is the partition function.
It is the sum s
that we are after,
but we can also, and we've seen
this already how to do this,
express the sum in the
numerator graphically.
And the difference between the
numerator and the denominator
is that I have an additional
sigma sitting here,
an additional sigma
sitting there,
that if left by themselves
will average out to 0.
So I need to connect
them by paths
that are composed of
factors of t sigma sigma,
originating on one and
ending on the other.
Right?
So in the same sense that what
is appearing in the denominator
is a sum that
involves these loops,
the first term that
appears in the numerator
is a path that
connects zero to r
through some combination
of these factors of t,
and then I have to sum over all
possible ways of doing that.
But then I could
certainly have graphs
that involves the same thing.
And the loop, there
is nothing that
is against that, or the
same thing, and two loops,
and so forth.
And you can see that as
long as, and only as long
as I treat these
as phantom objects
that can pass through each
other I can factor out this term
and the rest of 1 plus
1, loop plus 2 loop,
is exactly what I have
in the denominator.
So we see that under the
assumption of phantomness,
if phantom then this
becomes really just
the sum over all paths
that go from 0 to r.
And of course the
contribution of each path
is how many factors of t I have.
Right?
So I have to have a sum over
the length of this path l.
Paths of length l will
contribute a factor of t
to the l.
But there are
potentially multiple ways
to go from i0 to r in l steps.
How many ways?
That's precisely what
I call this 0w of lr.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why does
a graph that goes
from 0 to r in three different
ways have [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you want to have
to go from 0 to r,
you want to have a
single path, and then
you want that path to
do something like this?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That doesn't [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's fine.
If I ignore the
phantomness condition
this is the same
as this multiplied
by this, which is a term that
appears in the denominator
and cancels out.
AUDIENCE: But you're
assuming that you
have the phantom condition.
So this is completely normal.
It doesn't matter.
PROFESSOR: I'm not sure I
understand your question.
You say that even without
the phantom condition
this graph exists.
AUDIENCE: With them
phantom condition--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --this graph
is perfectly normal.
PROFESSOR: Even without
the phantom condition
this is an acceptable graph.
Yeah.
OK.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So what
does phantomness mean?
Why then we can simplify
only a [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Because let's say I were
to take this as a check
and multiply it by
the denominator.
The question is, would
I generate a series
that is in the numerator?
OK?
So if I take this object that
I have said is the answer,
I have to multiply
it by this object.
And make sure that it introduces
correctly the numerator.
The question is, when does it?
I mean, certainly when
I multiply this by this,
I will get the possibility of
having a graph such as this.
And from here, I can
have a loop such as this.
And the two of them would
share a bond such as that.
So in the real Ising
model, that is not allowed.
So that's the
phantomness condition
that allows me to
factor these things.
OK?
All right.
So we see that if I have this
quantity that I have written
in red, then I can calculate
both correlation functions,
as well as the free energy,
log of the partition
function within this
phantomness assumption.
So the question is,
can I calculate that?
And the answer is that
calculating number
of random walks is one
of the most basic things
that one does in
statistical physics,
and easily accomplished
as follows.
Basically, I say that, OK,
let's say that I start from 0,
actually let's do it
0 and r, and let's
say that I have looked at
all possible paths that have
l steps and end up over here.
So this is step one, step
two, step number three.
And the last one, step
l, I have purposely
drawn as a dotted line.
Maybe I will pull this
point further down
to emphasize that
this is the last one.
This is l minus 1
is the previous one.
So I can certainly
state that the number of
walks from 0 to r in l steps.
Well, any walk that
got to r in l steps,
at the l minus one step
had to be somewhere.
OK?
So what I do is I do a number
of walks from 0 to r prime,
I'll call this point r
prime, in l minus one steps.
And then times the number
of ways, or number of walks
from r prime to r in one step.
So before I reach my
destination the previous step
I had to have been
somewhere, I sum
over all possible various places
where that somewhere has to be,
and then I have to
make sure that I
can reach from that somewhere
in one step to my destination.
That's all that sum is, OK?
Now I can convert
that to mathematics.
This quantity is start from
0, take l steps, arrive at r.
By definition that's the number.
And what it says is that this
should be a sum over r pi,
start from 0, take l minus
1 steps, arrive at r prime.
Start from r prime,
take one step,
arrive at your destination
r, sum over r prime.
OK?
Now these are n by n matrices
that are labeled by l.
Right?
So these, being n by n matrices,
this summation over r prime
is clearly a matrix
multiplication.
So what that says is
that summing over r prime
tells you that that is
w 1, w of l minus 1, 0.
And that is true for any
pair of elements, starting
and final points.
So basically, quite
generically, we
see that w, the matrix
that corresponds
to the count for l steps, is
obtained from the matrix that
corresponds to the count
for one step multiplying
that of l minus 1 steps.
And clearly I can keep
going. wl minus 1,
I can write as w 1, w of
l minus 2, and so forth.
And ultimately the
answer is none other
than the entity that
corresponds to one step raised
to the l power.
And just to make things
easier on my writing,
I will indicate this as
t to the l where t stands
for this matrix for one set.
OK?
This condition over
here that I said
in words that allows me to write
this in this nice matrix form
is called the
Markovian condition.
The kind of walks that
I have been telling
you our Markovian in the
sense that they only they
depend on where you came
from at the last step.
They don't have memory of
where you had been before.
And that's what
enables us to do this.
And that's why I had to do the
phantom condition because if I
really wanted to say
that something like this
has to be excluded,
then the walk must
keep memory of every place
that it had been before.
Right?
And then it would
be non Markovian.
Then I wouldn't have been able
to do this nice calculation.
That's why I had to do this
phantomness assumption so
that I forgot the memory of
where my walk was previously.
OK?
Now...
Yeah?
Question?
No?
So this matrix, where
you can go in one step,
is really the matrix of
who is connected to whom.
Right?
So this tells you
the connectivity.
So for example, if
I'm dealing with a 2D
square lattice the sides on my
lattice are labeled by x and y.
And I can ask, where
can I go in one step
if I start from x and y?
And the answer is that either
x stays the same and why y
shifts by one, or y stays
the same and x shifts by one.
These are the four
non zero elements
of the matrix that allows you to
go on the square lattice either
up, down, right, or left.
And the corresponding
things that you
would have for the cube
or whatever lattice.
OK?
Now you look at
this and you can see
that what I have
imposed clearly is such
that for a lattice
where every side looks
like every equivalent
side this is really
a function only of the
separation between the two
points.
It's an n by n matrix.
It has n squared elements,
but the elements really
are essentially one
column that gets
shifted as you go
further and further down
in a very specific way.
And whenever you have a matrix
such as this translational
symmetry implies that
you can diagonalize it
by Fourier transformation.
And what do I mean by that?
This is, I can define
a vector q such
that it's various components
are things like e to the i
q dot r in whatever dimension.
Let's normalize it
by square root of n.
And I should be sure that
that is an eigenvector.
So basically my statement is
that if I take the matrix t,
act on q, then I should get some
eigenvalue in the vector back.
And let's check that for
the case of the 2D system.
So for the 2D system, if I say
that x y t qx qy, what is it?
Well, that is x y
t x prime, y prime,
the entity that I
have calculated here,
x prime, y prime qx, qy.
And of course, I have a sum
over x prime and y prime.
That's the matrix product.
And so again, remember
this entity is simply
e to the i qx x prime
plus qy y prime, divided
by square root of n.
And because this is a set
of delta functions, what
does it do?
It basically sets x prime either
to x plus 1, or x minus 1,
y prime either to y or
y minus 1, y minus 1.
You can see that you always
get back your e to the i qx
x plus qy y with a
factor of root n.
So essentially that
by the delta functions
just changes the x
primes to x at the cost
of the different
shifts that you have
to do over there, which means
that you will get a factor of e
to the i qx, e to the minus
iqx, with qy not changing,
or e to the i qy,
and e to the minus i
qy with the x
component not changing.
So this is the standard
thing that you have seen,
is none other than 2 cosine
of qx, plus cosine of qy.
And so we can see that quite
generally in the d dimensional
hypercube, my t of
q is going to be
the sum over all d components
of these factors of cosine
of q alpha.
And that's about it, OK?
So why did I bother to
this diagonalization?
The answer is that that
now allows me to calculate
everything that I want.
So, for example, I know
that this quantity that I'm
interested in,
sigma 0 sigma r, is
going to be a sum over
l, t to the l, then 0.
wl is t to the l times r.
Right?
Now this small t, I
can take inside here
and do it like this.
And if I want, I can write this
as the 0 r component of a sum
over l tt raised
to the power of l.
So it's a new matrix,
which is essentially
sum over l, small t times this
connectivity matrix to the l th
power.
This is a geometric series.
We can immediately do
the geometric series.
The Answer is 0, 1 over 1 minus
tt going all the way to r.
OK?
And the reason I did
this diagonalization is
so that I can calculate this
matrix element, because I don't
really want to invert
a whole matrix,
but I can certainly
invert the matrix when
it is in the diagonal basis
because all I have to do
is to invert pure numbers.
So what is done is to
go to the Fourier basis
and rotate to the Fourier
basis calculate this.
It is diagonal in this basis.
I have q r.
And so what is that?
These are these exponentials
here evaluated at the origin,
so it's just 1 over root n.
This is 1 over root n.
This is e to the i
q dot r over root n.
This is just the eigenvalue that
I have calculated over here.
So this entity is none
other than a sum over q, e
to the i q dot r
divided by n, two
factors of square root of n.
1 over 1 minus
t-- well, actually
let's write it 2t-- sum over
alpha cosine of q alpha.
And then of course I'm
interested in big systems.
I replace the sum over
q with an integral
over q, 2 pi to the
d density of states.
In going from there to there,
there's a factor of volume,
the way that I have set the
unit of length in my system.
The volume is actually
the number of particles
that I have.
So that factor of n disappears.
And all I need to do
is evaluate this factor
of 1 minus 2t sum over alpha
cosine of q alpha integrated
over q Fourier transformed.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I notice that
you have a sum over q,
but then you also have
a sum alpha q alpha.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a relationship
between the q and
the q alpha or not?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So that goes back here.
So when I had two
dimensions, I had qx and qy.
Right?
And so I labeled, rather
than x and y, with q1 and q2.
So the index alpha is just a
number of spatial dimensions.
If you like, this is
also dq1, dq2, dqd.
AUDIENCE: OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
All right.
So we are down here.
Let's proceed.
So what is going to happen?
So suppose I'm picking
two sides, 0 and r,
let's say both along
the x direction,
some particular distance apart.
Let's say seven, eight apart.
So in order to evaluate this I
would have an integral if this
is the x direction of something
like e to the iq x times r.
Now when I integrate over qx the
integral of e to the iqx times
r would go to 0.
The only way that
it won't go to 0
is from the expansion of
what is in the denominator.
I should bring on
enough factors of e
to the minus iqx,
which certainly exist
in these cosine factors,
to get rid of that.
So essentially, the mathematical
procedure that is over here
is to bring in sufficient
factors of e to the minus i
q dot r to eliminate that.
And the number of ways that
you are going to do that
is precisely another way of
capturing this entity, which
means that clearly if I'm
looking at something like this,
and I mean the limit that t
goes to be very, very small so
that the lowest order
in t contributes,
the lowest order t would
be the shortest path that
joins these two points.
So it is like connecting these
two points with a string that
is very tight.
So that what I am saying
is that the limit as t
goes to 0 of something
like sigma 0,
sigma r is going to be identical
to t to the minimum distance
between 0 and r.
Actually, I should
say proportional,
is in fact more correct.
Because there could be
multiple shortest paths
that go between two points.
OK?
Now let's make sense.
There's kind of an exponential.
Essentially I start with
the high temperature limit
where the two things don't
know anything about each other.
So sigma 0, sigma
r is going to be 0.
So anything that is beyond
0 has to come from somewhere
in which the information
about the state of the site
was conveyed all
the way over here.
And it is done through
passing one bond at a time.
And in some sense, the
fidelity of each one
of those transformations
is proportional to t.
Now as t becomes
larger you are going
to be willing to pay
the costs of paths
that go from 0 to r in a
slightly more disordered way.
So your string that
was tight becomes
kind of loose and floppy.
And why does that
become the case?
Because now although these
paths are longer and carry
more factors of this
t that is small,
there are just so many
of them that the entropy,
the number of these
paths starts to dominate.
OK?
So very roughly you can state
the competition between them
as follows, that the
contribution of the path
of length l, decays like t to
the l, but the number of paths
roughly grows like
2d to the power of l.
And since we have this
phantomness character,
if I am sitting at a
particular site, I can go up,
down, right, left.
So at each step I
have in two dimensions
a choice of four, in three
dimensions a choice of six,
in d dimensions a choice of 2d.
So you can see that this
is exponentially small,
this is exponentially large.
So they kind of
balance each other.
And the balance is
something like e
to the minus l over some
typical l that we'll contribute.
And clearly the
typical l is going
to be finite as long
as 2dt is less than 1.
So you can see that
something strange has
to happen at the
value where tc is such
that 2dtc is equal to 1.
At that point the cost of
making your paths longer
is more than made up by
increasing the number of paths
that you can have, the
entropy starts to be.
And you can see that precisely
that condition tells me
whether or not this
integral exists, right?
Because one point of this
integral where the integrand is
largest is when q goes to 0.
And you can see
that as q goes to 0,
the value in the
denominator is 1 minus 2td.
So there is
precisely a pole when
this condition takes place.
And if I'm interested
in seeing what
is happening when I'm in the
vicinity of that transition,
right before these paths become
very large, what I can do
is I can start exploring
what is happening
in the vicinity of that pole.
So 1 minus 2d, sum over
alpha cosine of q alpha,
how does it behave?
Each cosine I can
start expanding around
its q going to 0 as 1
minus q squared over 2,
so you can see that this
is going to be 1 minus 2td.
And then I would have
plus t q squared,
because I will have q1 squared
plus q2 squared plus qd.
So this q squared is
the sum of all the q's.
And then I do have
higher order terms.
Order of q to
fourth, and so forth.
OK?
So if I'm looking in the
vicinity of t going to tc,
this is roughly tc q squared.
This is something that goes to
0 and once I factor out the tc,
I can define a length
squared in this fashion,
inverse length squared.
OK?
PROFESSOR: You can see that
this inverse length squared is
going to be 1 over tc 1 minus
2d, which is 1 over tc times t.
So you can see that this is
none other than tc minus t.
And if I'm looking at the
vicinity of that point,
I find that the correlation
between sigma 0 sigma r
is approximately
the integral ddq
2 pi to the d, Fourier transform
of the denominator that I said
is approximately 1 over
tc times q squared plus z
to the minus 2.
We've seen this before.
You evaluated this
Fourier transform when
you were doing Landau Ginzburg.
So this is something
that grows when
you are looking
at distances that
are much less than
this correlation
length as the Coulomb power law.
When you are
looking at distances
that are much larger than
the correlation event,
you get the exponential
decay with this r
to the d minus 1 over 2 factor.
So what we find is
that the correlation
of these phantom
loops is precisely
the correlation that we had
seen for the Gaussian model,
in fact.
It has a correlation
length that diverges
in precisely the
same way that we
had seen for the Gaussian
model with the square root
singularity.
So this is our usual mu
equals 1/2 type of behavior
that we've seen.
And somehow, by all
of these routes,
we have reproduced some
property of the Gaussian model.
In fact, it's a little
bit more than that,
because we can go back
and look at what we
had here for the free energy.
So let's erase the things that
pertain to the correlation
length and correlations,
and focus on the calculation
that we kind of left in
the middle over here.
So what do we have?
We have that log of S
prime, the intensive part,
is a sum over the
lengths of these loops
that start and
end at the origin.
And the contribution
of a loop of length l
is small t to the l.
And since w of l is
the connectivity matrix
to the l power, it's really like
looking at the matrix element
of this entity.
And of course, there is this
degeneracy factor of 2l.
And I can write this
as 1/2 sum over l.
Well, let's do it
this way-- the 0 th,
0 th element of sum over
l dt to the l over l.
And what is this?
This is, in fact,
the series expansion
of minus log of 1 minus dt.
So I can, again, go
to the Fourier basis,
write this as minus 1/2
sum over q0, 0 q log of 1
minus t the eigenvalue
t of q, and then q0.
Each one of these is
just the factor of 1
over square root of n.
The sum over q goes over
to n integral over q.
So this simply becomes minus
1/2 integral over q 2 pi
to the d log of 1 minus t,
this sum over alpha cosine of q
alpha [INAUDIBLE] 2
that we had over here.
And again, if I go
to this limit where
I am close to tc, the
critical value of this t,
and focus on the
behavior as q goes to 0,
this is going to
be something that
has this q squared plus c to
the minus 2 type of singularity.
And again, this is
a kind of integral
that we saw in connection
with the Gaussian model.
And we know the kind of
singularities it gives.
But why did we end up
with the Gaussian model?
Let's work backward.
That is, typically,
when we are doing
some kind of a partition
function of a Gaussian model--
let's say we have some integral
over some variables phi i.
Let's say we put them on
the sides of a lattice.
And we have e to the minus
phi i some matrix m ij phi
j over 2 sum over i and
j implicit over there.
What was the answer?
Then the answer was
typically proportional to 1
over the determinant of
this matrix to the 1/2,
which, if I
exponentiated, would be
exponential of minus 1/2
logarithm of the determinant
of this matrix.
So that's the general
result. And we
see the result for
our log of S prime
is, indeed, the form
of 1/2 minus 1/2
of the log of something.
And indeed, this sum
over q corresponds
to summing over the
different eigenvalues.
And if I were to
express det m in terms
of the product of
its eigenvalues,
it would be precisely that.
So you can see that
actually, what we
have calculated by
comparison of these two
things corresponds to
a matrix m ij, which
is delta ij minus t times this
single step connectivity matrix
that I had before.
So indeed, the
partition function
that I calculated, that I called
Z prime or S prime, corresponds
to doing the following--
doing an integral over phi i's
from the delta ij.
Essentially for each phi
i, I would have a factor
of minus phi i squared over 2.
So essentially, I
have to do this.
And then from here,
once it's exponentiated,
I will get a factor of e to the
sum over ij this t phi i phi j.
So you can see that I started
calculating Ising variables
on this lattice.
The result that I calculated
for these phantom walks
is actually identical if I had
to replace the Ising variables
with just quantities
that I integrate
all over the place,
provided that I weigh them
with this factor.
So really, the difference
between the Ising
and what I have done
here can be captured
by putting a weight for the
indirect integration per site.
So if I really want to
do Ising, the weight
that I want to do
for the Ising-- let's
do it this way--
for phi has to have
a delta function at minus 1
and a delta function at plus 1.
Rather than doing
that, I have calculated
a w that corresponds
to the Gaussian
where the weight for each phi
is basically a Gaussian weight.
And if I really wanted to
do the Landau Ginzburg,
all I would need to do is to
add here a phi to the 4th.
The problem with this
Gaussian-- the phantom system
that I have-- is
the same problem
that we had with
the Gaussian model.
It only gives me one side
of the phase transition.
Because you see that I did
all of these calculations.
All of these calculations
were consistent, as long
as I was dealing with t
that was less than tc.
Once I go to t that
is greater than tc,
then this denominator that
I had became negative.
It just doesn't make sense.
Correlations negative
don't make sense.
The log, the argument that
I have to calculate here,
if t is below-- is
larger than 1 over 2d,
then it doesn't make sense.
And of course, the reason the
whole theory doesn't make sense
is kind of related
to the instability
that we have in
the Gaussian model.
Essentially, in
the Gaussian model
also, when t becomes
large enough,
this phi squared is
not enough to remove
the instability that you have
for the largest eigenvalue.
Physically, what
that means is that we
started with this taut string.
And as we approached
the transition,
the string became more flexible.
And in principle, what
this instability is telling
me is that you go below
the transition of t greater
than tc, and the string
becomes something
that can go over and over
itself as many times,
and gain entropy
further and further.
So it will keep going forever.
There is nothing to stop it.
So the phantomness condition,
the cost that you pay for it,
is that once you go
beyond the transition,
you essentially
overwhelm yourself.
There's just so much
that is going on.
There is nothing
that you can do.
So that's the story.
Now, let's try to finally
understand some of the things
that we had before, like this
other critical dimension of 4.
Where did it come
from, et cetera?
You are now in the position
to do things and understand
things.
First thing to
note is, let's try
to understand what this
exponent mu equal to 1/2 means.
So we said that if I think
about having information
about my site at
the origin, that
has to propagate so that further
and further neighbors start
to know what the information
was at site sigma 0--
that that information can
come through these paths that
fluctuate, go
different distances,
and eventually, let's say, reach
a boundary that is at size r.
As we said, the contribution of
each path decays exponentially,
but the number of paths
grows exponentially.
And so for a particular
t that is smaller
than the critical
value, I can roughly
say that this falls
off like this,
so that there is a
characteristic length, l bar.
This characteristic l bar
is going to be minus 1
over log of 2dt.
And 2dt I can write as
2d tc plus t minus tc.
2 d tc is, by construction, 1.
So this is minus 1 over
log of 1 plus something
like 2d, which is 1 over t
minus tc, t minus tc over tc.
Now, log of 1 plus a small
number-- so if my t goes
and approaches tc--
this log will behave
like what I have over here.
So you can see that this
diverges as t minus tc
to the minus 1 power.
I want it, I guess, to
be correct-- tc minus t,
because t is less than tc.
But the point is that
the divergence is linear.
As I approach tc, the
length of these paths
will grow inversely
to how close I am.
Now what are these paths?
I start from the origin,
and I randomly take steps.
And I've said that the
typical steps that I will get
will roughly have length l bar.
How far have these paths
carried the information?
These are random walks, so
the distance over which they
have managed to carry
the information,
c, is going to be
like the square root
of the length of these walks.
And since the length of the
walks grows like t minus tc,
this goes like tc minus
t to the minus 1/2 power.
So the exponent mu of 1/2 that
we have been thinking about
is none other than the 1/2
that you have for random walks,
once you realize
that what is going on
is that the length of the
paths that carry information
essentially diverges
linearly on approaching this.
So that's one understanding.
Now, you would say that this
is the Gaussian picture.
Now I know that when
we calculated things
to order of epsilon, we found
that mu was 1/2 plus something.
It became larger.
So what does that mean?
Well, if you have these paths,
and the paths cannot cross each
other-- it comes here, it
has to go further away,
because they are really non
phantom-- then they will swell.
So the exponent mu
that you expect to get
will be larger than 1/2.
So that's what's
captured in here.
Well, how can I really
try to capture that more
mathematically?
Well, I say that in the
calculations that I did--
let's say when I was calculating
the correlation functions sigma
0 sigma r, in the
approximation of phantomness,
I included all paths
that went from 0 to r.
Among those there were paths
that were crossing themselves.
So I really have to subtract
from that a path that
comes and crosses itself.
So I have to subtract that.
I also had this condition
that I had the numerator
and denominator that cancel
each other, which really means
that I have to subtract
the possibility of my path
intersecting with another
loop that is over here.
And we can try to incorporate
these as corrections.
But we've already done that,
because if I Fourier transform
this object, I saw that it
is this 1 over q squared
plus k squared.
And then we were calculating
these u perturbative
corrections, and we had diagrams
that kind of looked like this.
Oops, I guess I want to
first draw the other diagram.
And then we had a diagram
that was like this.
You remember when we
were doing these phi
to the 4th calculations,
the corrections
that we had for the propagator,
which was related to the two
point correlation function, were
precisely these diagrams, where
we were essentially subtracting
factors that were set by u.
Of course, the value
of u could be anything,
and you can see that there
is really a one to one
correspondence.
Any of the diagrams that
you had before really
captures the picture
of one of these paths
trying to cross itself
that you have to subtract.
And you can sort of put a one to
one mathematical correspondence
between what is going on here.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So why
can't we have the path
in the first
correction you drew?
Because aren't we
allowed to have
four bonds that
attach to one site
when we're doing the
original expansion?
PROFESSOR: OK, so I told
you at the beginning
that you should keep track
of all of my mistakes.
And that's a very subtle thing.
So what you are asking is,
in the original Ising model,
I can draw perfectly OK a
graph such as this that has
an intersection such as this.
As we will show next
time-- so bear with me--
in calculating things while
in the phantom condition,
this is counted three
times as much as it should.
So I have to subtract that,
because a walk that comes here
can either go
forward, up, or down.
There is some degeneracy
there that essentially, this
has done an over counting
that is important,
and I have to correct
for when I do things more
carefully next time around.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When you did
the Gaussian model,
we never had to put
any sort of requirement
on the lattice being
a square lattice.
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: Didn't we have
to do that here when
you did those random walks?
PROFESSOR: No, I only use the
square condition or hypercube
condition in order
to be able to write
this in general dimension.
I could very well have
done triangular, FCC,
or any other lattice.
The expression here would
have been more complicated.
So finally, we can also
ask, we have a feel
from renormalization
group, et cetera,
that the Gaussian exponents,
like mu equals to 1/2,
are, in fact, good
provided that you
are in sufficiently
high dimension--
if you are above
four dimensions.
Where did you see that
occurring in this picture?
The answer is as follows.
So basically, I have ignored the
possibility of intersections.
So let's see when that
condition is roughly good.
The kind of entities
that I have as I
get closer and closer to
tc in the phantom case
are these random walks.
And we said that the
characteristic of a random walk
is that if I have something
that carries l steps,
that the typical size in
space that it will grow scales
like l to the 1/2.
So we can recast
this as a dimension.
Basically, we are used to
say linear objects having
a mass that grows--
what do I want to do?
Let's say that I
have a hypercube
of size L. Let's actually
call it size R. Then
the mass of this, or
the number of elements
that constitute this object,
grow like R to the d.
So if I take my random
walk, and think of it
as something in which
every step has unit mass,
you would say that the l
is proportional to mass
so that the radius grows
like the number of elements
to the 1/2 power or the
mass of the 1/2 power.
So you would say
that the random walk,
if I want to force it in terms
of a relationship between mass
and radius, that mass
goes like radius squared.
So in that sense, you can
say that the random walk
has a fractal or
Hausdorff dimension of 2.
So if you kind of
are very, very blind,
you would say that this
is like a random walk.
It's a two dimensional thing.
It's a page.
So now the question is, if I
have two geometrical entities,
will they intersect?
So if I have a plane and a
line in three dimensions,
they will barely intersect.
In four dimensions,
they won't intersect.
If I have two surfaces that
are two dimensional, in three
dimensions, they
intersect in a line.
In four dimensions, they
would intersect in a point.
And in five dimensions, they
won't generically intersect,
like two lines generically don't
intersect in three dimensions.
So if you ask, how bad
is it that I ignored
the intersection of objects that
are inherently random walking
in sufficiently
high dimensions, I
would say the
answer geometrically
would be in intersection
is generic if d
is less than 2 df, which is 4.
So we made a very
drastic assumption.
But as long as we are above
four dimensions, it's OK.
There's so much
space around that
statistically, these
intersections, this non
phantomness, is so entropically
constraining that it never
happens.
You can ignore it, and
the results are OK.
But you go to four
dimensions and below, you
can't ignore it, because
generically, these things
will intersect with each other.
That's why these diagrams
are going to blow up on you,
and give you some important
contribution that would swell,
and give you a value of mu
that is larger than the 1/2
that we have for random walks.
So that's the essence of
where the Gaussian model was,
why we get mu equals
to 1/2, why we
get mu's that are
larger than 1/2, what
the meaning of these diagrams
is, what four dimensions
is special.
All of it really just comes
down to central limit theorem
and knowing that the sum of
a large number of variables
that has a square root of n type
of variance and fluctuations.
And it's all captured by that.
But we wanted to really
solve the model exactly.
It turns out that we can
make the conditions that
were very hard to implement
in general dimensions
to work out correctly
in two dimensions.
And so the next
lecture will show you
what these mistakes
are, how to avoid them,
and how to get the exact value
of this sum in two dimensions.